all these sort of far left extremists
they're very effective online so within
hours my wikipedia was changed to is a
fascist
and you're like what the [ __ ] is going
on
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantin kizen and
this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
musician and a friend of the show
winston marshall welcome to trigonometry
thanks constantine thanks francis how
are we yeah we're very good it's been a
while since uh we've wanted to get you
on we've been obviously chatting you've
been round we've been having theological
debates we've been talking about all
sorts of stuff and we just thought it'd
be great to get you on the show uh for
us to have this conversation like this
um but i have an agenda you have an
agenda yeah do you i do what is your
agenda i am plugging my own podcast
mate so
what you do is you do some interesting
stuff first okay and then you go and by
the way i was talking to
alexander schwarzenegger's son on my
podcast and you do that later so we'll
talk about your podcast we'll play
winston
[Music]
okay no we got that though that was good
that was great it wasn't i'm glad we
opened with that so winston uh since
we're talking a foreplay let's let's do
a little bit of that tell everybody a
little bit about who you are how are you
where you are and what has been your
journey through life now of course you
were a musician for a long time then you
had your own sort of self-cancellation
which we'll talk a little bit about uh
but you've you've actually had an
interesting life in general so just tell
us everybody who are you and how are you
here
uh i my name is winston yeah we've
established stuff
we've also established i'm a musician
and i
started playing the pub circuit around
london as a teenager um with various
bands my first band gobbler's knob
uh was this was a zz top cover band the
name was inspired
uh from groundhog day
classic i'm sure you remember and uh
then i was in a country rap band a crap
band
called captain kick and the cowboy
ramblers
we were
we were never the same lineup for each
show but we were always at least nine
players and it was a total shambles and
we had an american sleaze rapper sort of
smutting his way over some very out of
time and out of tune
stringed instruments
and that would lasted about a year and
uh we did talk we ended we did tour the
uk
in a um
very messy
uh
shambolic um
yeah that was that was fun that was kind
of actually no one lasted that tour it
was like an eight-day tour across the uk
and
and it started about 15 of us and by the
last gig
there were only four and i was
organizing and i wasn't even at the last
gig it just kind of like disintegrated
over time uh and then um from that
started playing
um sessioning with various bands uh
still in london uh laura marling was one
alessie's arc
and a few others and
and then that
kind of evolved into
mumford and sons uh that would have been
2007
and
that band
just we really clicked and
um for
14
years it kind of was a bit of a miracle
and it and it went very well we were
toured relentlessly and the stars
aligned for us we were very lucky in
many ways but those three guys are
[ __ ] talented as well so combination
hard work talent and and a lot of good
luck and it was kind of
amazing and um
and then but now
i am no longer in that band and uh
that
oddly
uh
is
because i suppose
of a tweet
um
uh i tweeted about andy knows book
online and in the in the in the panda in
the lockdown i was
tweeting about the books i was reading
was like a little minor theme on my
social media that wasn't really being
followed by anyone which was which makes
the what happened next even more bizarre
uh but
uh
one of the books i tweeted about was
annie nosebook and
uh
even i think on twitter i had like three
thousand followers or something so no
one and then within a day or two
it blew up and it was a positive tweet
it's like you're a brave guy it's an
important book and which i thought it
was as far as i know at the time or knew
it was the only book on
anti for far left extremism in the
states and i'd been living in the states
before so i was
even though it seems like a niche topic
for a guy living in london like it was
it was a topic that
wasn't didn't seem that niche from the
life i was living in in america and and
also i suppose
when the
mainstream media was so ignoring the
file affliction and covering far right
extremism rightly but didn't cover far
left extreme in the same breath so i
guess maybe
that's why i was curious about it and
that's why perhaps i came to the book
um and uh
yeah that that completely blew up
and um
before long i sort of apologized for the
offense it caused
and then over the few months after that
my conscience just
sort of uh
i just it felt was wrong but i that i'd
apologize because i don't think that was
actually anything wrong with the book
i mean there's no book there's above
criticism obviously even shakespeare but
um apart from the good book
[Laughter]
yeah um
so so even though you know i i kind of
just kind of was went into it deep i was
like what's wrong with this book what's
wrong with the author and there's lots
of criticisms there's a lot of [ __ ]
nonsense and and
uh
lies written about um the author and
and i i was i guess
aware of that as well because a lot of
those lies then came at me you know for
example
like
they changed your wikipedia all these
sort of far left extremists they're very
effective online so within
hours my wikipedia was changed to is a
fascist
and you're like what the [ __ ] is going
on and um
and for and for like a lot of you know
the friends in their life who don't
understand
the culturals or don't understand
they'd never heard of the book maybe
never heard of antifa never understood
the topic
they see all this and they're like what
the [ __ ] what's you know what's going on
here
and so that and they want to sort of
protect you at the same time they don't
really understand what's going on so
it just it was like a total
it's a very hellish period um
uh privately um and and publicly i guess
but
uh
so as i kind of got to
into this
more i realized like
i it was it was wrong of me to have
apologized i don't think it was wrong
with me to apologize
for bringing that kicking that hornet's
nest and bringing the those
you know that that that um storm onto
onto my colleagues onto my bandmates i
think it was right for me to apologize
to that and i stand by that apology but
but i but
i the kind of conundrum i had was like
well it's not true for me to
you know there's nothing wrong with this
book
um or or certainly
so i certainly stood by at least let's
play this way i stood by my original
tweet he is a brave guy and it is an
important book
um have you read the book yeah we've had
andy on the show to talk about it yeah
do you what do you think he's a brave
guy
well andy's definitely a brave guy i
mean people can quibble with some of the
things he says i personally haven't seen
anything worth quibbling over but people
do and as you say no books above
criticism but
i mean guys got brain injury for
reporting on on extremist organizations
so well that's actually in the period
between my initial apology and when i
quit the band
he was attacked again yeah and actually
that footage has just come out last week
so now i've so i heard about it but now
i've actually seen the footage it's
[ __ ]
[Music]
and
and i remember being like it was just
like another like you you know you
you're on you're assisting these
evildoers these violent hooligans
in in apologizing because you're
accepting that they're right they're
they're right but they're not right but
the problem i had was that if i
say or said
no actually i stand by i said then my
band mates were
going to get in loads of [ __ ] like
little examples that radio stations said
they were not going to play the band
um
for me personally i was supposed to dj
at one
festival that i got
uh you know cut from the bill
because the headliner they wanted to
condemn me online a lot of musicians and
artists even ones we'd worked with but
not all but obviously but a lot had you
know
come after me in a nasty way online or
like in an at home in any way
not just criticism criticism is fine but
like gone a bit further than that
and so
my conundrum was do i
live a lie to protect
or stand by a lie
to protect
the band or
protect the band and leave which is
where the conclusion i came to
uh which meant that i didn't have to
um
lie or and they wouldn't suffer for the
truth that i thought i was telling
and that might seem like
uh
like like not such a
big
thing but for me it was like quite it
was a hellish few months as well like i
was not sleeping
i was like it was felt like a a
a puzzle i couldn't escape from i was
like
like and and
i didn't see a good way out of it so
anyway well i actually think now
it's been difficult rebuilding since but
you know i'm a big boy uh i'll be all
right uh but
um
coming through now uh
uh you know life's sort of slowly
building it back up against us we'll see
well you know you're someone who who
thinks very carefully about things and
one of the things that that struck me
was when we
france and i came up to your house you
kind of invited us your house so for the
listeners i'm a huge fan of you both as
comedians and have been following you
both uh well before
all of the events that i yes yeah well
actually you were a comedy unleashed and
you messaged me and that's how we
connected so i don't think you would i
saw your show yeah in january 2020 yeah
out of comedy unleashed yeah
and thought it was great yeah um
and then yeah touch base yeah that's so
so you want to find a trigonometry
initially you were a fan of of us
comedically i think more more than i
think yeah yeah exactly yeah so but but
anyway when you kindly invited us to
your house uh it's not the tidiest house
and that's because sorry winston i
didn't mean to offend you
it's because it's covered in books
right you've got books everywhere
and they are books from people
like andy no they're books from people
who would be the very opposite you're
clearly someone who likes to take in
different perspectives think about
things you read about history you read
about philosophy you read
and it's
it's it's clear to me that you're
someone who thinks carefully in the
nuanced way and is very interested
um
and i i think the the reality of your
situation partly is that we no longer
live in a world
that is understands that that's possible
that you can read a book and think
someone's brave without necessarily
being right wing or read a book and
think it's interesting without
necessarily being left-wing or and i
think that's kind of partly what you
came up against that
you're sort of measured by each tweet as
in
independently of your entire track
record as a human being
yeah and if you went through the other
books i was reading that i was tweeting
about i was like
[ __ ] mao you know what i mean
and and you know that's actual evil
um
yeah i mean perhaps on you know
reflection
perhaps well i definitely didn't
understand twitter for the the thing
that it was and and if you
the whole point is each tweak does have
its life of its own as soon as it's out
there and
and it's almost like a statement if
you're for some people
tweeting is just like trying to thought
but for other people or like artists i
guess or institutions
each tweet is a there's a statement and
i guess i got that wrong which i'm now
apparently now i get that
what a way to learn the lesson
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
ridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anthem has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge are such
great guys they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
obviously it shocked you by by what
happened with the tweet but did it shock
you the behavior of your fellow artists
because one would think that
particularly in the music industry
you know rock and roll freedom
[ __ ] the man i'm gonna say what i think
what i want
did that surprise you that there was
that backlash
i was surprised by
a couple of the artists to who said
stuff who i'd work with because
um
they could have done it privately
instead of adding fuel to that fire
um again i don't think anything's above
criticism so fair enough you know uh if
they felt like they needed to
um
but then yeah the idea i'm and i'm and
absolutely
it's as i said i only had a few thousand
followers so it was insane to me within
it
within like a day or two it was on the
view and tucker carlson is like what i
like like how is this you know just
seemed like an act of god
which yeah
and and so
um
with the other artists
it doesn't really surprise me
that i i do think all you know all i've
written about this in a
piece for barry weiss last week um her
common sense substance
all communities all um groups are prone
to
a a a certain amount of homogeneity of
thought and that's absolutely
normal it's forgivable it's definitely
not good
um
but
what can you expect in particular the
music industry when
it's a it's a community of people
who
will have similar personality traits and
being open and and
the only
and
i it's not that strange that there's a
kind of
kind of agreed upon um
or or a popular opinion within a group
even if it's not popular no actually
barry white sent me a
because i did a interview with her and i
didn't do very many interviews but i did
one with her
because i just wanted to get my story
out and i didn't i wasn't from like
trying to promote i just wanted to get
set the record straight so i just did
her yeah such high regard for us so you
didn't do it with us by the way
i did i am
uh yeah and um but barry sent me a
uh one poll which i
should dig out but
that antifa in the states had a five to
six percent approval rating
which is the that is the fringe that's
like now in america five or six percent
of people is a lot of people right but
nevertheless
as a as a society that's the fringe of
society and and
that's the extremist i mean that's
probably what the far right is five or
six percent probably less even yeah yeah
is that right um
uh so
uh it was an extreme thing and they're
very effective they know what they're
doing online
they know what they're doing or they
looks like they
do they know what they're doing in real
life well i don't know but uh uh they're
causing all sort of all sort of all
sorts of havoc and
and um
um damage and it's it's appalling um
uh so uh where we're going
we were talking about were you shocked
by the reaction of your fellow artists
yeah so um i was
i was shocked but again i i i sort of
understand
now with hindsight oh well twitter's
kind of that's the world i was engaging
in
and
also i do think that
artists generally i do think there's a
problem a problem with homogeneity of
thought in the creative industries like
you see this and this is what i wrote
for barry last week is
whatever the topic is
unorthodoxy
is established pretty quickly and even
if
um
this doesn't mean everyone
disagrees like for example on antifa i
think the only other musician that's
publicly outspoken on antifa is nick
cave who
um on his blog
has written about it criticizing them
and um i know he got pushback from from
doing that um but otherwise i don't
think there's many who have um and
because i do think there's probably a
decent amount of of consensus within the
industry even if society at large
doesn't there isn't evidence of that
consensus
but
you see you've already been very
diplomatic winston and and i understand
why because i think you're a far more
conciliatory person than i am
but it because but it enrages me it
enrages me because the whole point of
art to me whatever type of art is is
that it should be welcoming and
celebrating of a diverse of diverse
viewpoints
it should challenge the status quo it
shouldn't be just one particular
viewpoint is celebrated and everybody
else should be silenced
that to me is anathema to art surely
well that's what has been particularly
shocking
this year with with uh what's happened
to rogan
um
it's it's artists
forming their own leading the mobs yeah
against
freedom of expression it's and again i'm
not saying that rogan's first amendment
rights are
in question here although the white
house did follow up
by saying yeah more needs to be done to
combat misinformation
but it's artists like neil young crosby
stills and nash uh here it was stuart
lee here it was joni mitchell joni
mitchell um who are
closing down conversation i mean their
whole
career the whole
job is expression
so how can they not see the
the the the kind of
paradox there well you actually saw
signs of this before
your tweet because yeah you were doing
interviews not in a cultural way
necessarily with the band
when you were touring
yeah so for sure so so
i the last tour in the last record well
let's put it this way like
we did a record in 2015
and then we did another record in 2018.
so and we're doing promotion for then
2019. in 2015 none of the questions were
about politics in 2018 none of the
questions were about music
and that's and that and that's a bit
piffy and it's not
totally true but that's kind of how it
felt like a little bit
um
and something about
essentially brexit and trump
meant that all the interviews were like
trying to get in even though the music
wasn't remotely political
it's not remotely relevant to the
to the music um and to the product and
to the album into the band or not in my
opinion
um and
and then there was there are certain
topics
that
yeah there was group consensus on in the
industry
so doing interviews i i got to a point
where i was you know very nervous going
interviews because it was so i'm gonna i
don't want to say the wrong thing get my
bandmates in trouble
um because they're probably going to ask
about the in politics
um
whatever topic it might be
um
and
even though i don't think there are
opinions that are publicly
particularly controversial at all um
that's just you know an exam i think
there's a lot i was sensitive to it
because
um
the photograph uh come out with jordan
peterson
who i was
was and i'm a great admirer of and
it kind of blew up to be this thing it's
like what like and he's this is a guy
sold millions of books he's incredibly
popular
um he's um
uh
changed so many lives for the better and
and um obviously he's divisive and
there's some people uh who who
dislike him um or at least dislike
the person they think he is
um
but and then after that it's like wow
well like if what i can
i don't think he's remotely
controversial so if if that if a topic
like that can blow out like that like
anything can go like that so you'd go
into these interviews
and you'd so you'd be very hesitant
about saying anything at all even though
you were being asked about it you're
being asked political questions there's
a musician who's not political and you
just sit there going i really don't want
to say the wrong thing and and the
interviewers generally
or not generally but would often either
have an agenda or you could almost be
certain that the way they would present
it
would be not
fair it would be they would be pushing
their own agenda
um
[Music]
because they would care about the topic
or
you can see this with
some of the um
legacy music
um
magazines like nme it's incredibly
political i think they had
jeremy corbyn on the front cover and
it's like of a music magazine like what
what's i think that would have been
when would that have been 20
was that was it 2019 that election yeah
um
so you know all these music magazines
where it's not it's not politics we're
putting
we're turning into political magazines
with an agenda
and so you couldn't i was just like well
they're not they're obviously not going
to present this fairly so i don't want
to engage in this
conversation like that did you feel did
you ever have conversations with other
artists talking about how
they felt that the overton window was
narrowing and how things were becoming
more fraught
so
now i haven't gone through this
experience i've had amazing artists
very high profile
not just in music but across the board
and i'm going to go back all the time
like will be remembered for
centuries-type and i'm not going to name
them but we have the same yeah and again
most of them won't say anything publicly
but yeah yeah but we all love eric
clapton
[Laughter]
um
uh so
there's definitely
a lot of artists that
that see this is as
the ridiculous
situation that is and then hopefully
that will
i think i sense it will like jessica
like last week for example
there's a photograph of skrillex came
out with
jordan and michaela and it's like
um
and he's a big artist
and i imagine he's probably getting a
bit of flack behind the scenes but i i
don't know if he'll be surrounded by
good people anyway
um and it sends like and more and more
people
do that and it's just like it will
expose the lunacy
of the of the stay of
those industries
by just more and more people having the
courage realizing that there aren't like
skrillex is untouchable so more people
like that do that
do you think it's going to help but the
fact that the music industry because of
the internet because of social media
because of spotify it's losing its power
it can't really shut people down like it
used to like if you were dropped by your
record label in the 90s i mean that was
potentially career ending
and it for many many people but now if
your record label drops you can still
release your own stuff you can you can
still have a career
you could definitely release your own
stuff and um you don't need any of that
stuff but music industry is very small
um and pretty much everyone knows each
other so
uh
it depends what kind of career you want
if you want to be
huge you do need the industry to get to
that level but if you just want to
release music you don't you don't you
can just release music
and so you still think that if you're
dropped by your label it that's still a
ma that's still a career ender
potentially
i i think so i think so it doesn't stop
you from putting out
music but i do think
it's it stops you from getting to a
certain level it's a very significant
deterrent in other words
to making sure that that doesn't happen
for you
um and winston one of the things you
talked about your apology and and i i
wanted to explore this because you and i
have talked about this in the past
because you apologized really because
you wanted to protect your band
right would that be fair to say
yes
and then you you sort you regretted the
apology because it wasn't authentic to
who you are but you still wanted to
protect your band yes right um i didn't
regret the apology to the band yes yes
exactly that's what i meant um and the
reason i'm delving into it is that i
think one of the things that happened
with you is when you did apologize
there was also a lot of people from the
other side
who then decided to come after you yeah
that was an eye-opener for me i was like
oh yeah you guys behave exactly like the
people you you've been taught to be
uh against the anti the anti-woke mob
they're they're just as quick to cancel
people as as the
the you know the progressives on the
other side and and that uh
um
you know now i hope you get cancelled
and this kind of stuff it was really
quite helpful for me to see that i was
like oh yeah
and um
i would be very reluctant to kind of
take that go flip onto that that side of
things for sure there's another sort of
inspiration for me
in that sense um was i mean someone i've
spoke about so much so that it's
probably boring at this point but um
uh in snitzen's warning to the west and
he he came over and he gave a
bunch of lectures across the um
uh the uk and and and the states
i suppose it would have been the 70s or
80s um
i'm not sure exactly uh when but um
he he comes over and he could and he
still loved
russia it was his country
uh but he he could very much have
you know it's cold war he could have
come and been like
[ __ ] russia
like america and and america you know
america would have loved him but he came
over and he criticized america people
went off him very quickly when he did
they did he could have played to the
crowd he could have and and and it would
have turned him to into another
he didn't buy into any of that and and
he saw he saw it for
or
or he i mean that's real i mean that's
integrity to another level
um and
uh that's the that's the nut sort of the
archetype really i think
it's the
dealing with that sort of
the mobs and crowds and
um it's the opposite to like politicians
politicians have to play to the mob to
further their careers and that's the
great thing about an artist is he
doesn't well actually an artist darts in
in a weird way but scott smitson didn't
let that affect him
the reason i bring it up is something
that francis and i've been
thinking about a lot and dealing with
because
there's no question that we are not woke
and against workers we are we are
anti-work right
but
the the problem is
if you are anti-cancer culture
and you then engage in canceling people
because they said something you didn't
like
or you know i see this quite often you
know on youtube you'll get somebody on
who's more left leaning or who may be
woke even and you want to have a
conversation with them and people i'm
not watching this you know and it's like
well you're not anti-cancer culture then
you're just anti-that cancer culture and
you actually quite like to engage in
your own thing and so
and that's the evolution of all of us i
think initially for us as artists as
comedians that was the feeling like this
this industry has become very
homogeneous and everyone's supposed to
have the right opinion i'm against that
but then also as you as you move away
from that you're starting to to see the
flaws in some other arguments and and
you know we're generally trying to build
our own picture of
issue by issue topic by topic subject by
subject as you do with the books that
you read
um and
the i think it's it's big tech it's
social media it's just designed to to
just push you into an echo chamber it's
just pushing you you either work or
you're anti-work you know you can't just
be human being with different opinions
like it it's going to feed you this is
going to feed you that do you know what
i mean absolutely and it's great that
you've identified that and and as you
you know take trigonometry forward
um
and this is how i say for example for me
another
it's not exactly
speaking to that but
i got invited to every
news
thing on under the sun and i've been
very careful to like not go on to
certain shows because i i you know i
don't need to like so i can play to now
the anti-work crowd very easily
but i don't because i don't want to play
that game at all i don't engage that
game i want to i know what it's like to
lose my integrity and i want to [ __ ]
keep hold of it keep holding my bloody
soul and and just
kind of see above it and see and not
play quick you know games which you're
in tricky position because you're
building a business so you kind of need
to play quick games but at the same time
people
will see through you in the long run we
never we never looked at it like that
man we never ever looked at it like that
yes of course now we have staff and
people helping us make the show we've
got to make sure that we've got a salary
to pay them but
we think of it as the integrity
that we tried to maintain and look we're
human beings and we're fallible
but
it's the integrity that attracts people
so
when we say this is our opinion and now
we've changed it for example
because we've changed our opinion that
to me is what people recognize as human
beings and you hope that there's an
audience out there for that but it's
like when i started comedy i people
would always ask me you know comedians
are desperate to succeed and whatever
and i always said if i can't do the
comedy that i want to do i don't want to
be a comedian
it's part of the reasons i don't do
comedy now anymore i feel like i've got
more interesting things to do
you know
uh i don't want to i don't want to play
to any crowd
you know
i do not find that crowd though
the crowd finds you
and the crowd i'm interested in playing
and i suppose if there is one is the
crowd of people who are interested in
exploring ideas and making up their mind
on an issue by issue and still retain
that genuinely liberal feeling of
i'm interested in hearing people that i
don't agree with
you know
that's the goal for us i think you've
done you've you've done well at that
inviting kind of range of people yeah
we're not interested i'm not interested
in being a partisan i'm not interested
to be a partisan left right or whatever
it may be it's an easier path to take
much easier because you find your tribe
and you can all agree and
we're built to seek the tribe we're
built to be part of the tribe that's how
we are evolutionary speaking but i don't
want that i'd much rather
be a part and actually have my own
thoughts and my own views and my own
sense of integrity than to be part of
a group where i have to become
disingenuous
and lie not only to other people but
more fundamentally to myself
but i i'm gonna ask this question
because i think sorry go for it and then
well
i found that with
now launching my new podcast and the
people i've got on it's a range of
people i think
i think probably all my guests
are liberal if not progressive
i don't think i have any conservatives
yet
um but
but and i certainly don't agree with
them on everything
um to different degrees but i want to
make them look good because they're
humans and uh
because uh there's no reason even if i
disagree with someone that they uh
they they should they aren't an
interesting and and nice person uh that
should be given the time and i think
that that's that vilification that
happens
when you get into the tribal stuff
it's so cheap it doesn't need to be like
that that's you can be mates like
everyone at home's got mates who they
disagree with massively but they don't
let that get in the way of their
friendships it should be the same on on
these sort of shows i think that's
starting to die out winston that's what
you said about people having mates that
they disagree with i actually agree i
agree with you on that yeah i think that
used to be since 2015 it's like you know
it's been very
you know yeah i think sadly that's going
that's starting to ep away
the question i was going to ask is is
the artist
i'm someone who's always been a big fan
of art music
film whatever else why do we
now believe that the artist has to be a
good person
when did we start judging the artist
for their actions and not for the art
they produce
he's asking you to defend pedophiles
[Laughter]
well the example that went to my head
was r kelly because i frigging loved
that song ignition but it was a banger
it's a banger it still is
germany do you have any moral qualms
listening to that song no i don't i
think this idea that we should judge
artists and say that you know if they
have done
reprehensible things which many of them
have done
suddenly we can't have access to all the
beautiful things that they've created
i find ridiculous like i'll give you an
example i'll give an example lewis
carroll probably a paedophile probably
everything that we know about him
allegedly allegedly right we're going to
get sued by the scout foundation
yeah
i'll get a message in my twitter yeah
eliminate that take it down right
created one of the most brilliant works
of children's literature in alice in
wonderland
i want to have i want to have children
if i have a little girl i will read her
alice in wonderland because i think it
is a book of brilliance it just is and i
taught it every every primary school
class i had
i taught we we read alice in wonderland
together
it's a magical book is there any artist
that committed a crime too much for you
to
enjoy their work or sponsor their work
because that's another line is if you
know that by listening to them or
watching them that they're getting paid
and that that money is then fueling
insidious behavior or inappropriate
immoral [ __ ]
then that's that's that's is there a
line there for you
because
you know you talk about people who are
dead it doesn't make a difference yeah
you know but
i i i i i i i don't want to pivot about
it
i also think it depends on what you're
talking about for example if you look at
someone the music may be different
somewhat but comedy
how you experience a comedian's material
depends very very much on what your
perception of their character is
it's one of the reasons someone like
jimmy carr gets into a lot more trouble
than someone else doing the same jokes
because jimmy carr
presents a kind of fairly normal person
on stage he's not vulnerable he doesn't
talk about himself it's all there's no
authenticity to it it's just jokes right
and so people look at the joke on it on
its own and he's not necessarily the
most likable persona on stage either
whereas if you took someone like jerry
sadowitz who says things that are way
worse than what uh jimmy carr says but
he he's cl his persona on stage is
someone who's completely mental right
and very one vulnerable and very sort of
unhinged and that means he can get away
with stuff that someone else can't so
the knowledge for example that
someone is a sex pest or whatever
changes how you experience the joke they
might do
about that issue right so i don't think
it's as simple as as as just going
well you know there are and the artists
are separate well on some some issues
some situations they are and then
someone annoyed it's much more complex
and i i don't have an answer i just know
that it's not a simple answer
what do you think
um
i i probably there's i can't really
think of an artist that i wouldn't
listen to i would still listen to r
kelly but r kelly's
r kelly's the only one because as far as
i understand it and this is
i'm not sure this is actually right but
he he's an interesting example because
he's someone who's still alive he still
profits
when you
listen to his music however i i don't
think he's still engaging in that
behavior
so you're not
funding you're not fueling that
necessarily
but the idea that uh artists are
infallible and moral moral uh
morally sort of
untouchable is
insanity and so um
you can't there's no art you can listen
or engage engage with or enjoy at all if
if they have to be a good guy because no
one's a good guy but but even more to me
art comes from fl from flawed people if
you think about some of the greatest the
greatest songs the greatest art
literature
a lot of it stems from pain
and when someone's in pain
quite often they inflict it on other
people
whether they intend to whether they
don't
an artist is never a well put together
person when they're at their creative
peak
so to then expect them to be this flawed
perfect person who's then producing
incredible works of art
to me the entire thing doesn't make any
sense it's completely incongruous
i just i just see the way that we're
putting artists on a pedestal now
and expecting them to be perfect
both from what they create and in their
private lives and in their political
opinions and in who they are it's
completely ridiculous
agreed
and i've never i've never let so let's
say political opinions because that's
maybe where it's
most relevant to my life
i have no problem listening to
like
marxist communist musicians
um like that even though it's obviously
an abhorrent and and completely immoral
uh political uh ideology uh that's
killed hundreds of millions it doesn't
mean i can't enjoy the music i have no
problem separating um
those things but i don't think that
that's
the case for everyone i think that we're
in a period where
it's not the art that's judged it's the
it's the person
by whatever
kind of whatever the fatty morals of the
day are
hey constantine do you believe every
business needs cyber security to succeed
yes of course because otherwise uncle
vlad will hack the hell out of it
wouldn't that be a gross violation of
international law input in russia we
don't have law well if you don't live in
russia then pocket seam is the company
for you if you have a business that
needs protecting from the unscrupulous
elements of the internet
then make sure to check them out
unscrupulous elements that is no way to
talk about my family
pocket seam also provides free resources
if you follow them on twitter and
linkedin and if you want to keep costs
manageable you can also pay for their
services on credit pocketseem is the
best and most cost-effective cyber
defense company in the world i tried
hacking them and all i got was
international sanctions if you want to
protect your company
at a reasonable price then go to
pocketseam.co.uk
that's p o c k e t s i e m dot co dot u
k and get your company protected by the
best in the business
well let me ask you this because um
you're a religious person and a lot of
people have made the comparison that the
the thing we're going through now is a
sort of new religion if you like
but one that has no forgiveness and has
no redemption of any kind
do you think that's what it is do you
see sort of religion or cult-like
features in what's happening now
i certainly think we're
bringing back to the book
that's got me in trouble on the like
topic topic of antifa i do think when
you look at i do feel sorry for these
these kids who are engaging in this
stuff and and one reason is
that that
they've replaced where they don't have a
god or
a ritual or community like that that
religion brings in the church they
replace it with this other thing which
brings them tremendous meaning
um and and so there is a
that that is
this is one of the kind of consequences
of of
god dying in in
modern times
so i do i do agree with that um and i do
think that i mean i've written about
this a bit as well but good faith and
the i and just remembering that we're
all flawed
that's i try to work out why
why that is not what so many of my
friends still talk about goodies and
baddies
like like life is a disney film but even
a disney film's got more nuance than
that
and but i'm trying to work out i've been
just thinking about why is it that
um
that's that so many people see the world
because that's not christian thinking at
all
um christian is very much that we're all
the thought is that we're very much all
flawed
um uh and
one of the reasons is maybe i think
we've been taught history really wrong
like um with
nazism it's which everyone learns in
school which they should learn in school
um
it's you know nazi's bad
uh
brit's good
um or or allies good rather
and and so
and because that's quite an easy story
to tell perhaps that's one of the ways
we see the world and that's maybe why
nazi is the word that comes up so often
when you're having political arguments
like if you're
you're pro-brexit you're a nazi that
that was happening a lot of that kind of
but actually and the other side as well
you're kind of
uh remain a fascist you know there's
it's not just one side doing that um
i i wonder if that and
before the interview started kind of a
little bit towards the idea of like
communism why is that so difficult to
teach and is that taught and you're both
from
from uh communist
backgrounds i know it's difficult to
teach at all
do you know no it's not difficult to
teach at all i think it's very difficult
to teach why do you think it's difficult
to teach because the the thing i hear so
often is uh even from friends my
intelligent friends my age all like oh
yeah well it's
it's uh
conceptually brilliant it's just
practically speaking
that's what i think no but that's
nonsense it's conceptually it's
it's it's
taking into account human nature and
it's you know and that so conceptually
it's nonsense
you know what i take back what i said
you're right it is conceptually nonsense
what i mean is it's well intentioned uh
with some people some people i'm not
even sure it's well-intentioned for some
people it is for some people it's not
for some for some people it's just about
the opportunity to turn the tables and
to be the authoritarian and at the top
telling other people what to do i'm at
the bottom now i want to switch
everything so i end up on top and a lot
of people who led the russian revolution
were motivated by that but some of them
were also motivated genuinely by a
desire to uplift people and to share and
and and whatever
i think there is unfair society yes
there's no one who doesn't really well
there's probably people who don't yeah
no young people do but i don't think
communism is very difficult to teach i
could teach communism to a class of kids
in an hour
i'd like to be in that class it's very
easy all you do is you take some
resources like sweet or whatever and you
you get
get some of them to produce them let's
say to make them or whatever and then
you distribute equally to everybody see
what happens
see what happens
see what happens when one person sits in
a corner doing [ __ ] all and one person
is doing all the work and then you
distribute everything equally over and
over and then the person who did nothing
gets to demand from that other person
what they should and shouldn't do
see what happens it's not that hard to
teach the reason we don't teach it is
historical in my opinion you asked me
this before that's why i'm answering
we needed
some the soviet union to win we the west
right the west needed
me
the soviet union if you like um i'm
getting very confused now
[Laughter]
the west needed the soviet union to win
the war and to defeat narcissism and
because of that it meant that they were
willing to turn a blind eye to
all the atrocities
seriously churchill didn't by the way
churchill churchill yes he throughout if
you read him throughout that period he's
like this is we've made a deal with the
devil here yeah uh absolutely but uh if
you this is one of the my favorite
things people who read all will
obviously read 1984 at an animal farm
etc but if you read the preface to
animal farm
uh he talks about how difficult it was
to get it published because criticizing
the soviet union at that time and which
of course animal farm does very directly
was seen as
one ought not to do this thing it's
called i think uh on censorship is his
essay which i recommend everybody read
um
you know it was a pragmatic decision
um
and also
people in britain people in america were
not affected directly by
uh communism for the most part the how
many how many how many british people
died fighting against communists
how many british people were
taken to concentration camps by
communists how many british people
were repressed by communists very very
well the story is even worse than that
and it's from your your great mighty
guest charles ud who you recommended
thank you whose book labour and the
gulag should should be
mandatory reading i think in schools in
britain um but the the period the
feeling at the time um uh after the
russian revolution
and for a long time afterward was you
mustn't criticize
uh
the the socialism and communism in
russia uh because um it's you know we've
got to support it so even when there
were stowaways on ships of the timber
that was being uh cut down by um uh
gulag uh prison
slave labor that you know the timber
itself had
had carvings like help
um in cyrillic or whatever so obviously
they couldn't really read it but there
were actual stowaways that ended up in
britain and that stuff was ignored so
that the revolution could be supported
but i don't think it's difficult to
teach no i don't think it's difficult to
teach now as someone who's got a
teaching background it's relatively
simple to teach your big mistake is
doing it with sweets because the little
[ __ ] would eat
well
even better what you do is you get them
to all to make something then you get
them all to sell it make the money yeah
and then you split it equally between
people who've done absolutely nothing
and and people who worked hard see how
long that lasts that is going to last
about a day mate it's not it's not hard
to teach it's just about being willing
to teach yeah but again your the example
well not again but
you're not it's not a t you're you're
it's a practical thing so you're still
not articulating
why communism bad's there you're just
saying try this kids whereas with nazism
you could be like
oh you and you are like this was an evil
ideology where they they prioritized
race over common humanity and these were
the consequences
whereas you still haven't
uh well that part is if you mean what is
the intellectual argument against
communism that i don't find that
difficult to articulate at all i just
think if you're going to teach people
practical ways of doing it are usually
much better because they experience it
directly right
but intellectually
the idea that
that uh
that we should pretend
that human beings are not aspirational
that human beings are not hierarchical
the human beings didn't evolve to seek
to be more successful than other people
in society and that that is a healthy
desire in a very large way which is why
we live in a in a
you know in in this world instead of mud
huts
right i don't think that's difficult to
explain to people and whenever francis
talks about his experience of venezuela
or i talk about and as i do in my
upcoming book about communism or the
experiences i haven't found many people
who've struggled to understand that what
i have found is that even very
well-educated people here in the west
have absolutely no [ __ ] idea
what actually happened in the soviet
union what actually happened in china
what actually happened in venezuela what
actually is happening in cuba what
actually is happening they just don't
know it's shocking
you know knowing educated adults who
have never heard of mao yeah and i
wonder what the polls are there if you
if you look at like who you know who was
stalin who who are these people and i
bet you'd be appalling like there's just
no education on it but you see the
problem is is that we don't prioritize
the teaching of history at the schools
we touch on it very very lightly right
the way through primary right the way
through secondary you get what an hour
of history education
at school yeah every week
everybody's back yeah an hour a week are
you getting
yeah an hour maybe two hours a week
which if you look at the practicalities
of school it's five minutes to get the
kids in set up the lesson then five
minutes to pack away at the end so 50 45
minutes of quality teaching i mean
really can you go into depth into any
particular subject not really
so the reality is
we we just don't teach history most
people have a very very poor and limited
grasp of history
and that's the reality of it which is
the reason a lot of the time where you
saw
like you saw people marching down the
street during the blm demonstrations
saying things like abolish capitalism
and you know i had lots of friends um
you know who were in the comedy industry
they were neither intelligent nor well
educated but we're going to skip past
that and they were saying things you
know like oh this is great and guy go do
do you know what that means
do you actually know what that means
have you ever seen capitalism abolished
and they would just look at me and i'm
just like so why may do that chant
unless you know what that chart means
unless you know the implications of that
john unless you know what effects it's
going to have on society and the people
around you
don't do the chant
and that's the problem because
what it is is a utopian fantasy
it's a utopian fantasy
and you're asking people to believe in
this utopian fantasy but like all
utopias it doesn't lead to a utopia it
leads somewhere incredibly dark but
because people haven't been educated
about it
you can lead them down the path i'll
give i'll tell you the story um i used
to live in wimbledon
and there was a coffee shop down the
road for me and it was run by a cuban
guy and every week i would go in and
we'd sit down and i'd pick a moment when
the cafe shop was empty and we'd sit
down together eat and talk politics and
it was always one of the highlights of
my week
and i remember talking to him his name
was joel
and he he was and i was saying i was
really frustrated because at that point
the i could feel comedy the common
industry marching ever more leftwards
and it was really starting to frustrate
me
and he said to me i remember him saying
to me said to me francis
trying to explain
why communism is bad
to someone who's never really
experienced it
is like saying to somebody who's always
lived in a wonderful area
don't go down that path don't go down
the alley he said it's only when you
feel
the punch across the back of your head
it's only when you feel the blood in
your mouth that you ever truly
understand what communism is
so there is that element this is the
part i was trying to make earlier though
it's much easier to teach why nazism's
evil than to teach by communism because
the both of you are making the case to
teach how communism is bad you have to
like show it practically
no no no not necessarily you can teach
it it's a little bit more tricky because
nazism is so obvious you just say how
many people died in concentration camps
okay but but i'm going to argue with you
here let's say how many people died in
gulags it's more than in the holocaust
the holodomor which was the deliberate
starvation of people in in the western
parts of of the soviet union
killed more people than the than the
holocaust did it yes it was over seven
million that's the official figure
confirmed by the russian parliament it
was fine right it's more and probably a
lot more uh so
but there was also the racial element to
it which is just yeah you know and that
for whatever reason yeah that invokes a
stronger reaction it does it's true it's
true but let's look at the figures man
yeah okay i agree let's look at the
figures so if you if you the problem is
this is one of the things as well as
historically what happened with germany
after germany lost world war ii is there
was a very very very thorough
denatification program if you were a
german and you wanted to go and get a
food parcel from the allies to survive
which you needed to survive you'd go and
have to see a movie about what happened
in the camps that's what they did they
made you watch that right
did that happen in in russia in 91
no
no and the people who run russia are the
direct inheritors of the very people who
did the gulags the same people who used
to be in the kgb they now run the
country
so that's another reason there was no
decommunization thing there was in in
some parts in the western part in i
think estonia latvia lithuania they did
something about that
so i i just think it's not so it's not
so much that it's difficult it's just
that it hasn't been done
uh i don't know why that is do you think
do you have any thoughts on why that is
yeah
i don't think it's difficult man and
whenever we talk to people people who
are not necessarily open-minded to our
way of thinking
when you tell them what it was like
they understand
they understand but it's like a lot of
everything that's happening in society
now if you believe in utopias and you
care more about virtue signaling than
truth and you care more about
i your idea of what's right instead of
what actually works
yeah that's what you're going to end up
you're going to end up believing in all
this stuff
you know
francis and i've been talking about this
a lot you know
we're living through a period when
uh people are really embracing
utopianism again i don't i don't know
necessarily why
um but i think that's a big part of it
it's a big part of why these ideas are
coming back uh people maybe it's because
we're so comfortable now that we can
afford to be oblivious to reality we can
just be [ __ ] you know sailing away
with our thoughts in our own heads
it's also because it's a simple solution
to complex problems
if we do this then we're going to reach
the promised land
when the reality is there is no promised
land
and maybe these problems that we're
faced with at the moment
maybe they they certainly don't have
simple solutions
or even worse maybe there are no
solutions
maybe this is just what it is well look
at something look at something like our
conversations around racism for example
does anyone who's actually thought about
it for more than two seconds think that
a society
of human beings who evolved to be
suspicious of foreigners and of others
will ever get to a point where there is
no racism in society there's not a
single racist person ever
are we ever going to get to that place
no but that doesn't mean it's not worth
trying to deal with those issues in fact
i agree one must and um yes agreed uh
the problem is uh so so i absolutely
do think racism should be
you know fought against in combat but i
didn't say it shouldn't be see this is
this is where this is where we get into
the problem right i never said it
shouldn't be dealt with i said are we
ever going to get to a point where
there's not a single racist left in
society
right
and the problem is and actually peterson
who
talks about this a lot is the first 95
percent of the problem is usually
solvable with pretty simple and
normal means
the last five percent takes an awful
amount of social engineering to get to
right
and so we've now got to a point where i
think most of the normal ways of dealing
with the issue of racism have been
exhausted
and you are now doing things that are
actually counterproductive not you
personally you us the society right
where we are
we've got to a point where we think that
just chastising people
for saying the wrong word is going to
make them less racist well let's look at
the evidence
let's look at the evidence
since 20 since obama was elected
race relations improved
no they haven't
the more we bang on about institutional
racism and the more we talk about all of
this stuff
the more difficult this conversation
becomes
there's another problem is that the
solutions are wrong and this is an
example i gave in in
my piece with barry a couple weeks ago
which which was uh there was
a bbc
i was still with the band and we we did
a show with bbc orchestra and the
producer in preparation was insistent on
um doing uh having a racially diverse uh
orchestra which of course is nothing at
all wrong with having a racially diverse
orchestra um although uh
her approach was that it should be
uh that the the
orchestra would be chosen by their
immutable characteristics rather than
their hard work and skill
and a lot of people would argue yeah
that's how you deal with
racial inequality
and and
and i'm absolutely prepared to
uh uh
agree that that that there is racial
inequality but i wouldn't say that then
picking people by the the color of their
skin is the art so blind uh
right
auditions would be the answer but here's
what people don't even my point so the
solutions are all out of whack exactly
but that's that's exactly what i'm
saying you're reinforcing the point that
i'm making which is if you start
discriminating against some group
in order to correct past mistakes are
you going to create less racism or more
racism
if you keep discriminating against the
majority of people in this country i
felt this so much because i
for a period i was going back and forth
between england and america and that
country is so racialized
and they see everything through the
prism of race not and obviously i'm
generalizing about a hell of a lot of
people but it's by compared compared to
british
uh society and and in the last couple of
years we're taking that on which is just
horrible like
moving back to england i was like god
i've escaped that kind of racialized
nightmare um of of seeing the world
through that that lens when when i think
beforehand i thought britain was pretty
good at not
you know well right but let me and there
was racism in society before but let me
ask oh of course it's really awesome but
let me ask you this right because
how do you get people
from different racial groups to get on
better
how do you do that we were we visited a
friend of ours who watches trigonometry
and she was telling us about a plumber
that comes around to her house who also
now thanks to her telling him something
watches trigonometry
and she was saying oh she's like oh i
love that interview and love yeah you
know to explore such different topics
but the only thing i'm not sure about is
the jews
big labor man
[Laughter]
and
francis was kind of like sort of i don't
know what your reaction to it was
exactly but
my reaction to it was good
good
this person has some kind of thing that
he's got about the jews right and now
he's watching
a show hosted by a jewish man
right co-hosted by a jewish man
and enjoying it and before he knows it
he's gonna go oh maybe maybe that he'll
start with maybe they're not all like
that
right that's where we start and then it
will continue down the path it's
intermarriage it's living together it's
being friends it's having mates who are
muslims it's having mates who are jewish
it's having mates who've come from
another country who are dark-skinned
light-skinned that's how you solve
racism you don't solve racism by
chastising people by insulting people by
telling them that they should be
discriminated against because people who
looked like them 200 years ago did
something that you now don't like
that was accepted all around the world
as the normal way of doing things by the
way right you don't solve racism by
doing that you make it worse and that's
why you're seeing the racial tensions
increase instead of decrease
because you're
you're creating it
you're creating it
you know and it does my head and that's
why i'm so against it so in the sense
that i am anti-woke i am very anti-work
for this reason because they're making
things worse
agreed
great
but you know what you said
you said you wanted to ask us questions
so we're giving you a bit of yeah
so
we finally come here to the end of the
interview before we ask you not only our
last question but also our questions for
our supporters
plug the podcast
thank you so much uh i am uh following
your footsteps
starting my own show with the spectator
interviewing comedians actors
writers everyone in the creative
industries to try and work out what the
difficult atomic issues are which you've
been doing but i'm looking more
specifically i guess
at the arts and uh so far we had
ignat solzhenitsyn which was alexander
who is alexander's son
speaking about
his work as a composer and conductor in
the classical music world
and uh also he's an expert on his
father's work and uh we talked about
live not by lies which is the essay
alexander published
right before
uh leaving and got a little bit of a
disagreement because
you know this essay is like if you don't
stand up for what you believe you're a
cargo you're not a [ __ ]
you're a coward or you're a craven and
um
and and
ignat sort of made the case that it
wasn't actually that stronger it was
more of a gentle plea
um but anyway that was very interesting
and david bedear we spoke about jews
don't count his
book um i do think anti-semitism is
one of those serious issues um
uh anti-semitism is
like israel palestine as well as one of
the israel palestine is an example of
a topic that the creative industries are
completely orthodox on and actually
unlike other issues
it's a bit more of an anti-establishment
position
but
i think last year there was the
musicians for artists there's over 600
musicians signing this anti-israel
declaration
1500 artists
signed another another similar such
thing and it's it's like well it's
really anti um
uh israel and um
then anti-semitism i think is certainly
linked to that but there's there's
another issue
um
that needs to is one of those sort of
difficult topics and and um
even hearing that
i've heard from jews privately and
who are very nervous even if they're
not pro um that you know they're
skeptical about israel they feel like
when that topic comes up they have to
keep quiet because it's one of those um
issues uh that that really sort of
angers and is very divisive
um and spoke to don mclean apparently he
saw it all coming
if you listen to the song american pie
uh he he's um
he saw this this state
of the world a long time ago
uh and i look forward to listening man
it sounds like a great bunch of guests
and i'm sure you've got plenty more yeah
lined up it's exciting man
i'm really keen to see what what happens
in the next stage of your journey thank
you um
and you're you know you're working
you're working your way through it and
it takes a little time sometimes you
know yeah to work out exactly what you
want to do and how you want to be and
you're a very thoughtful man then you've
got plenty of books books to read i
think as well
thank you both for for giving me the
time uh and being so thoughtful in your
questions and for letting me plug my um
thing and supporting me and my new
you've been very supportive for your
listeners should know that you two have
been very supportive friends
uh behind the scenes as well as
in front of them and and i'm very
grateful for it and as you've been
wonderful uh
friends with me in this last couple
years so thank you thanks man thank you
it's a pleasure to know you um
we've got one more question for you
before we ask a couple of questions from
our audience only but winston the last
question we always ask is the same which
is what is the one thing that we're not
talking about as a society that you
think we really should be
the thing that pisses me off or
not pisses me off perhaps well certainly
occasionally pisses me off but
i can't quite work out is why the issue
of the uyghurs in china
uh where it's the largest internment of
human beings on
the planet at the moment it's between
two and three million or one in three
million
uh uyghurs in um uh camps uh in jinjang
and um we've got all sorts of heinous
horrific stories of uh
rape and
organ harvesting and
just the worst possible things you can
imagine and and it seems to me to be one
of the great atrocities happening right
now and
there's certainly a lot of there's been
a decent amount of coverage across the
board and and
it is one of those issues a bit like
hong kong which
which seems to in this country
be bipartisan in that there's no one
it's not a divisive issue it's
everyone's pretty much on the same page
i mean there are extremes who are
hesitant to criticize china but they're
i would say they're the extremes um uh
but the
nevertheless and even though let's say
the uyghur issues in hong kong gets a
fair amount of press coverage i don't
think it captures the imagination
of
uh
my contemporaries uh and and peers and
um
perhaps this is because
uyghur culture is so alien this is
another thing with
maybe one of the reasons why we got so
um the george floyd captured the
imagination all the way over here and
it's probably about the same similar
distance to how far away the
jinjang is from here
is because we're so marinated in
american culture growing up that it
feels like our culture whereas not only
is
is xinjiang a remote province of china
which is
completely unimaginable
unfathomable to us but china itself even
though it's the biggest country in the
world
is is i don't think it's something we're
educated on at all talk about being not
educated on communism earlier we're not
educated on china i certainly wasn't and
it's really difficult because the
language is very strange
uh or like very different to ours
uh
it's a difficult complicated long
history and and so china generally
speaking we i think it's something we
should all be striving to understand
better but the uyghur
that specific
ongoing tragedy
i think needs more attention um and for
any guests who are interested in
learning more about the uyghurs i
recommend following rahima mahmut who is
in britain she's a she's a wiga who
uh she's also a singer um and she does
various
performances which we've been working
together putting on cultural events
together in the uk to try and
enlighten or or try and uh show us the
the the other side about uyghurs that
isn't just the horrible things that
happening because what is weaker culture
what is weaker food there's various
weaker restaurants across
london there's not many uyghurs in the
uk i think there's about 500 leaguers
here um uh but maybe if we can paint the
picture of who they are and their
wonderful music their wonderful
traditions then uh
so we can eventually push the needle on
this horrible heinous
atrocity
winston it's been a pleasure thank you
very much thank you so much for coming
on uh thank you for watching and
listening uh before we go i should just
say uh china is not the biggest country
in the world that's obviously russia are
you meant by population by population
yes but we are the biggest we are the
biggest
careful now uh anyway thank you guys for
watching we are back uh very soon with
another brilliant interview like this
one or all show all of them go out at 7
pm uk time and for those of you who like
your trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
it's a great pun uh-huh
it's it's a great pun once i got it this
is how you do in comedy by the way if
they don't laugh you just make them yeah
russian way anyway exactly
you